joining us now with reaction former
deputy assistant to the president Fox
News national security strategist dr.
Sebastian Walker NRA TV contributor Dan
bond Gino we've got to start the
president keeps making promises and
keeping him the idea that you will suck
up and bribe dictators and if only we're
a little nicer to the moles of Iran and
give them a hundred fifty billion
dollars then they'll be nice to us well
Prime Minister Netanyahu blew that out
of the water last week and still people
want to stay in this bad deal white
doctor Gorka because they don't listen
to the past they don't understand
history I spent last Sunday in New York
with some Holocaust survivors let me
quote a Holocaust survivor on his
lessons learned from World War two he
had a very simple message when a group
of people repeatedly calls for your
destruction sooner or later you should
take them seriously well guess what Iran
has been doing since 1979 Sean you don't
give them pallets of cash you don't sign
a deal that really doesn't stop them
acquiring nuclear weapons you stop them
from getting the weapons they wish to
use against us and our friends like
Israel the president knew this in his
bones the jcpoa ran deal had to be
killed he just put two nine-millimeter
bullets in its head you know damn Bungie
you know I I don't understand how we
don't learn the lessons of history the
idea that you can negotiate with despot
so bribe dictators bribe those that
threatened to to destroy America death
to America death to Israel is the case
of the Iranian Mo's and somehow money
and bribery will work didn't work in
North Korea it didn't work in this deal
it's never gonna work and I think the
only reason that Kim jong-un is now
willing to talk is because the show of
military force the president's good
relationship with China and the fact
that Kim jong-un knew he was going to
lose everything yes Shawn a couple
things on this he Iran deal first you
know someone should inform the Iranians
there was a deal okay this
never a negotiation it was a
manipulation the Iranians played the
Obama administration for fools Sean let
me ask you a simple question okay let's
just say let's get common sense here
let's just get dollars the donuts the
Iranians prevented us from looking at
military installations to inspect those
military installations for the
production of nuclear weapons Sean where
the heck do you think they're going to
produce a nuclear weapon the local
Walmart of course they're gonna do it in
the military installations I mean this
is common sense this was never a deal
this was Obama getting played the
Iranians never had any intention of
sticking to this deal and I applaud
President Trump for throwing his crap
deal out the window let's talk about
Gina Haspel she will say tomorrow I can
offer you my personal commitment clearly
without reservation under my leadership
at the CIA will not restart restart a
detention and interrogation program I'm
assuming that means we're not gonna have
another event like 9/11 which I think
created extraordinary circumstances dr.
Gorka nobody can make that statement I
think she's following the decisions that
have been made in the United States
since that time I have a specific view
on this I was a trained interrogator in
the UK I'm not a massive fan of enhanced
interrogation but sometimes when there
is a ticking time bomb and when you may
be saving thousands of lives then that
decision may have to be taken and
remember Sean as you told so many times
to the American people how many people
were under enhanced interrogation in
America that's really three we're not
talking about they said this isn't some
kind of labor camp where we're just
willy-nilly using this the worst of the
worst were compelled to give up
information that saved lives that's the
end of the story
that's were damned Mangino yeah I agree
with Sebastian I'm not a huge fan of
enhanced interrogation showing the
problem is getting a precise definition
some of the definitions the left wanted
out there standing for a long period of
time
sleep deprivation that sounds like a
long day in the Secret Service where I
used to work so you know liberals
of us all a break and let's define
exactly what we're talking about all
right thank you both